we're just now going to go of the
application for premises license sifting
the parade Margate say t91 a way and I'd
like to ask a member of the licensing
authority to present the report Thank
You chair so an application has been
made by mark Hicks for a new premises
license at 50 in the parade Margate we
operate and schedule showing the
proposal activities and hours are
appended in annex report that you look
thin in summary it's to serve alcohol
into it between the hours of 10:00 a.m.
and 1:00 a.m. and late night refreshment
between 2300 and one because four
premises licensed are required as part
of the licensing procedure to display a
public notice which provides information
regarding the manner in which an
objection may be made application should
be published in a local newspaper
circulating unity of the premises these
requirements appears to have been
complied with two representations have
been received both of which are appended
in annex 2 both are objections regarding
public nuisance Environmental Health
have agreed following conditions with
the applicants the license area shall
only include the internal parts of the
premises from midnight on words each
operational night alcohol off sale
provisions should only be provided in a
sealed container all tables and chairs
on any form of seating associated with
the premises that no place on the Piazza
shall be removed by 20 to 30 onwards one
subcommittee you'll be aware that
mascara its functions under the 2003
licensing act to take steps which are
appropriate for the promotion of
Licensing objectives those objectives
are the prevention of crime and disorder
Public Safety the prevention of public
nuisance and the protecting our children
from harm in carrying out licensing
functions the subcommittee must also
have regard to our statement of
licensing policy and guidance issued
under the Act
objectives are the master device of
which the licences subcommittee must
address when considering whether to
grant or refuse this application each
application should be considered on its
merits and reasons must be given for any
decision made by the subcommittee where
premises licenses are granted mandatory
conditions will apply under sections 19
to 21 of the Act
I therefore ask the subcommittee for
their decision on this you'll see that
there are three options laid out in part
3 of the report thank you Thank You
penny okay something off with the
applicant okay something off yep Caen or
licensee including the calling of any
witnesses so questioning of napkin or
licensee and witnesses by responsible
authorities and interested parties and
so I'm sorry I mean just I'm not quite
sure from this this is it does he does
the applicant now need to basically talk
about their license or does the or do I
mean the licensing team are now able to
ask questions of the applicant okay so
the licensing team would like to ask
questions of the applicant now that'd be
great thinking I don't have any thank
you okay so next if members would like
to ask any questions of the applicant
that's great thank you Charlotte yes is
there any questions from members of the
committee today I become counselors no I
don't have any questions thank you and
neither me okay that I mean which I'm
just trying to ascertain which building
this is is this is this charlie so is it
is it Milo or is it what is it sound
like it's a next to it is it was what
was my lies
[Applause]
okay so so so I'm addressing the
applicant now am i okay and so this this
is them so um Milo's was a bar that was
open during the day and open during the
evening and had a license I think
probably till one o'clock and can can
you confirm that penny if it had like
the previous the previous some situation
I don't know the answer to that okay but
does the applicant know the answers to
and the previous situation with it with
the Milo's that was their tweet before
and the applicant I'll mute microphone
please pics is he still here
yeah mr. Hicks is still with us but he
just needs to UM meet his microphone
yeah I'm still here yes you did operate
at or one o'clock license and had done
for many years it was only when it was
changed use temporarily for under the
space of a year and he went to the
rat-race
okay and I mean I remember I remember
Milo's bar and the you know hours etc
vaguely
I mean I mean are you are you basically
and applying for the same conditions
that Milo's were operating under well
I've got I've got Jerry I don't know
whether Jeremy Jeremiah here my
solicitor and he was going to conduct
this meeting but I don't know whether we
missed his court name called at the
beginning because we were having
technical difficulties do you have him
listed he's most certainly been dealing
with the correspondence with licensing
department for on my behalf
okay thank you Charlotte it's okay
yes that should be okay okay and say say
ni assist of course the license for
Milo's had lapsed for one reason or
another mr. Hicks owns woodies next door
and he wanted to relicense what was
Milo's to effectively the same hours
which are the same hours as he has at
number 16 next door now there were two
ways of doing this one would be a
variation but the general guidance and
my understanding I think shared by Jane
Bennett is you do not apply for
variation if you're going to include he
increased the size of the premises by
more than one third the other
alternative was to apply for a
completely new license for the existing
woodies at number 16 and including
number 15 that we thought he best to
apply for a separate license port number
15 so it's a standalone license although
in practice the two will run together we
made the application on the same basis
as that for number 16 including the
Piazza but as a result of discussions
with mr. Brown which I can come to later
we would do that part of the application
relating to the Piazza so the license
will cover the building only and I can
deal with those aspects of a moment if
required so are the other other are the
young to building is going to be
operating as one as one Barra Strom know
they will be operated it is the same
management and all em do they have the
same licensing hours yes
okay the hours applied for are identical
to the hours next door okay thank you
very much for that can I just explain
back like engagement with mr. Brown mr.
Brown contacted me to say that he was
concerned about the extension of the
license onto the Piazza now if I can
deal briefly with a bit of history many
council licenses the Piazza to itself
Cafe G has a license on it and I think
Charlie is does
and in the days of mr. Bence did the
licensing manager officer everyone held
the license over the whole thing and
they each had their little slice to
operate on it was a rather informal
arrangement so I can I can I am inch off
for second and penny did you wanna
comment on that there's this site isn't
owned by TDC and we don't license that
site so yeah that is there may have been
a historic arrangement but we don't
actually license that well at one time
the council did for musical performances
anyway be that as it may mr. Brown's
concern was that since the advent of the
live music act he was no longer
necessary to have a license for
providing music between the hours of 8
a.m. and 11 p.m. and so he was concerned
that if we need license that the
accident we could introduce live music
onto the council under the live music
act which he thought was undesirable so
we agreed to withdraw the part of our
application relating to the P axis so
our license would not cover the piazza
and we have off sales so you know where
we can use that puzzle yes be next door
so the below you know you're freezing
it's my girlfriend thing
some point is and your your run you're
frozen
come on you back now
yes sorry I'm in the hands of mr.
Nixon's operating machinery because I'm
far too old to do all this now okay
Ellen I have also observed the objectors
I'm sorry
Tyson again yeah again it looks like
you've got bad internet connection there
yes I'm afraid the first objective is
shortened whose consent my only being
that I'm sorry I'm sorry about this then
tie it can you can you can you basically
let me know what the next hello and if
the applicant would like to ask their
lifespan team any question is that right
option two okay so I say good so much so
we would like to ask any questions of
them the licensing officer what our
specials are the licensee officer is
that right yeah okay great thanks
do you have any questions we have no
questions of the licensing officer okay
so Allison can you present the case
please yes if we if now if the members
could ask the licensing team any
questions do they have any this is all
better from me this is I'm following
this quit but it doesn't look like it's
another if I could just finish what I
was saying hello good nobody hear me
so yeah this yes we can mrs. woods yeah
you need to me I need to meet your
microphone just got it working I just
wanted to thank thank you mrs. words
sorry everybody
yes what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
remove you from the physical meeting so
please stay off the road but mrs. woods
was having technical issues getting into
the meeting so what mrs. winters Donna's
dialed in via the telephone the
telephone symbol in the when it comes up
that is that is mrs. woods okay
so sorry about that chairman so if we
return to mr. Dhillon
yes okay so so so currently mr. Dylan is
basically asking questions of the
licensing officer named Trevor that
point that we don't have any but we were
in the middle of explaining what we
intend to do and our reaction to mr.
Brown's objection which has been
resolved so I don't know whether you
wish me to continue further with that we
seem to got a bit out of order
if you continue then yes thank you
the second objection which is much more
detailed on the form objects quite apart
from the risk of noise after one o'clock
- the sort of takeover the react so my
premises around the Piazza I understand
that objection was probably filed while
our application included the use of the
Piazza that of course has now been
withdrawn so insofar as that objection
has been overtaken by events but as to
the general point the council agreed to
license the Piazza and four other
premises to put tables and chairs and
that's not really part of our
application last I understand the
objectors annoyance of this public area
seems to have been sort of sold off I
agree that way that's no longer part of
our application and his applicate his
objection or our objection is mainly
directed towards noise after one o'clock
well any noise there has been has been
from premises other than this one
there's no record as far as we are aware
of objections during the period when it
was my nose and my view is that if a
person is worried about noise then of
course if there is noise they can always
apply for a review so I hope that to
that extent I've dealt with the
objections I respect them I advise my
client that they're quite bona fide a
and the team was take care to live
peaceably with his neighbors I don't
think there's anything else that I can
usefully say apart from the fact mr.
brands intervention has removed what
might otherwise have been
controversy and that we are quite
content if the committee will lend it to
grant the license as it now is the same
hours as next door that would limited to
the interior and with the facility brav
sales with the restrictions of sealed
vessels after pledge to 30 and CC
midnight so that's all I have to say
well I'm very happy to answer questions
or for mr. Hicks to answer questions in
person of anybody objectors committee or
officers I'm sorry about the technical
difficulties but I'm in the hands of mr.
Hicks and his internet and 4G connection
is rather intermittent and I'm sorry I
can't do it myself but I've only just
mastered my iphone and without my second
almost in community card live okay right
thank you
and okay so and when do we do the
representation of people that objections
Charlotte well if the applicant and the
members don't have any questions to ask
the licensing team we could move on to
the object so if the ejector would like
to be let to so to speak and then be
questioned by the licensing team okay
that's right thank you so and so who do
we have here that some objectors Jessica
Woodson objector yes
okay Jessica like to UM put objection
forward please
mrs. woods it would appear that you've
muted your microphone I believe that
when you're dialing in if you press six
it'll unmute your microphone hi do you
hear me yes you are thank you I've been
several trouble with the mic I've gone
onto my phone now so just listening to
mr. histolytica am i right in hearing
that you are saying mr. Hicks that
you're not having any tables and chairs
on the Piazza for this particular venue
no we will be not not to this venue but
for next door for what do you mean next
door the what the the one that you're
you're having a license for now because
I thought we said he wasn't going to
have several chairs if I'm mistaken that
we're going to have them for good news
and the news venue is that correct no no
just for Woody's okay so just as it is
now you were not having any extra tables
and chairs outside for the new venue
it's just as she is at the moment
correct
okay can I ask you how many tables and
chairs you are licensed to have outside
for would you please was that another
question for another time in the region
of 20 do you have a license for the 20
mr. Hicks I do you do have a license
from KCC to have to have that amount
second chair I do indeed yes okay do you
have a license to keep them throw them
on the Piazza mr. hid under my license
I'm permitted to put the tables and
chairs on for the Creator the same as
anybody else on the Piazza it's on my
license oh yeah because I know you need
a license to keep the table chair I
thought that they under the licensing
Commission Committee of them sorry the
licensing regulations Securitate ensures
that they had to be removed they
couldn't stay there permanently
while what we went for is at when we
originally had that license we had to
bring the tables and chairs in we later
went through when the license and
officer was mr. Bence dead and we asked
if we could do the same as other people
and keep our tables and chairs outside
provided we cake that kept them secure
which we did mr. herring all right sorry
can you just bear with us for say no
Chairman I think penny button as they
had a safe neighborhoods would like to
come in at this point please okay and um
penny
sorry this chair it's just we're not
here only to talk about the application
for a new premises license at 15 the
parade not to talk about Woody's no I
Thank You penny okay my concern was
obviously having the tables and more
tables and chairs out because I live
right on the piazza and it is a terrible
noise the tables and chairs going in and
out day in the morning being put out and
I'm taken back up and putting the pile
on the Piazza but there's nothing I
didn't the tables and gestures and news
venue so I can't I've got no complaint
or objection about it because that's
what my Egyptian love the bow okay thank
you all right
happy licensing committee got any
questions following up from that of the
applicant no questions thank you no mr.
Dillon answered all mine I've got one
question and it's a good mine eyes that
she did have tables and chairs outside
so this one's not gonna have any tables
and chairs is that right well I
understand that mr. Brown because of
certain objections that come in didn't
he was
worried about the noise I mean we would
favor to have tables and chairs outside
you know we I mean I know we're not here
to talk about the license next door but
we're talking about responsibility
I've been operated a business here for
five years I'm not going to do anything
different we're not going to have loud
music or sorry thinking about your
responsibility is about your response to
me mr. Hicks but it's also you cannot be
fully responsible for your customers
when they are drinking alcohol and
getting drunk you can't be fully
responsible for that when I'm in bed and
I'm hearing terrible fights and
arguments given the recent events
especially on the stairs with the
violence and the noise and the throwing
of chairs continually and it's not like
just somebody digging a hole up outside
your house for five minutes or an hour a
day or for two weeks it may be six times
four months of the year every night in
the summer summer and then it's the
tables and chairs being put away so if
you are saying you're going for tables
and chairs and I'm going to come back
with an objection to that can i clarify
this position as a result of mr. Brown's
intervention there will be no additional
tables and chairs wrong number fifteen
on to the Piazza the only tables and
chairs that mr. Hicks is associated with
of those which is already permitted to
number 16 we did clarify please because
if mr. Hicks and putting tables and
chairs outside woody I'm sure that then
those tables and chairs will then take
more space outside the new property it's
correct mr. Hicks are you increasing
your amount of tables and chairs outside
of old milos the new property because
you're working under the license of
woody what I'm saying here is I would
like to but we've we've conceded that
because of mr. Brown's concerns that's
wonderful so how many favors and chairs
did you have outside Woody's last year
when your operational we're not here to
talk about well we're not used to talk
about Woody's but my concern is living
here as a resident and the excess noise
is that what's gonna happen is the ten
tables not even I don't
you have ten tables outside of Woody's
but I guess it comes down to what your
license too will then extend into and
seep into the area outside the new venue
so I hope and try on making that clear
and I'm making it a separate issue
though I mean that we're here to talk
about the licensing of milos and I mean
if this is situation where there's not
going to be any tables and chairs
attached the minors license that's what
we have sitting okay thank you for
reminding me it's just the noise of
potatoes and chairs yes absolutely but
if they get a license to sell alcohol
how are they going to stop people coming
out of their venue the new venue and
then sitting on the tables and chairs
outside wooded well maybe now will be a
time for Environmental Health to speak
and then if you like to question if
they've got to then be questioned by the
licensing team and by the members I
think if somebody could answer that
question I'd appreciate them good
morning chair and committee because we'd
agreed with the African prior normally
we wouldn't attend but given that there
were there were objectors we usually
attend just to ensure that the the
minimum that we'd agreed with the
applicant is still met so I've got a
short statement and my name is Christian
brown Obama protection I was with any
District Council was not overly
concerned at the time in my premises in
the area and by the addition of off
cells and a description within the
resubmitted application of the 12th of
the second described within the section
for the Prevention of public nuisance
the applicant had indicated they wished
in Lada since the Piazza area directly
in front of the premises this is
something the environment of health
would object to as due to the changes
inferred by the live music act this
would allow me be played externally
between 8:00 and 11:00
without how to cook
there are 130 I am given the premises of
surround robbers Delta we would
objective application in its original
form following consultation the
applicant through their agent we agreed
changes the application and to further
conditions these are outlined in the
reporting section 2.2 and been repeated
during this meeting in effect this will
prevent the external music and will
realize ins and the license of all
activity inside the premises from 20 to
30 on lagunas and then sealed complaint
of sales on the could made on the 5th of
march 2020 I would hope the conditions
and changes we agree with the applicant
would allow would allay any fears of the
public objector however they may wish
the subcommittee to move further I have
therefore amended the hearing to outline
our comments to be sure a complaint
business and we would look at tables
that were within the boundary of the
premise itself on the Piazza so if you
had a line from each premises going out
any tables outside would Eastwood will
be be part of and he can play so at
woodys table outside the adjoining new
funds it would be about my present in
terms of tickles
most of the premises drowning area have
some form of and we certainly wouldn't
look to control those and and I believe
22 our termination time is is more than
reasonable if we respect complaints we'd
love to take her with you and take that
back even further okay thank you
Christopher
the Charlotte yes
so does that wise looking have any
questions for Christopher does the
licensing and committee have questions
for Christopher nothing Captain Rogers
nothing happy with that
okay hello can anyone hear me okay okay
look Charlotte was the next second step
on this and one minute and Miss woods
and the officer Charlotte speaking well
so if environmental health I suppose we
went to the fire presentation so if
you'd like to have a final prostate
presentation miss woods and then we've
got then environmental health and then
the licensing team if they've got
anything else to say and then finally
from the applicant okay that's fine okay
so if you'd like if you'd like to say
what you've got to say and Jessica
whoops Jessica can a microphone
just like families yes come here home
thank you sorry I'm having really bad
trouble with his mic I'm sorry if I
interrupted anybody and I didn't quite
get everything that the years gentlemen
in primary health equity was a really
bad line all I really want to know is
because it seems very unclear to me in
my head there are tables and chairs
outside woody those tables and chairs in
primary health Boxer are they going to
stay directly outside woody can I assist
by saying there'll be no change in the
layout of the tables and chairs
associated with Woody's so as still so
so-called sneaked into any other area
the area outside the new premises will
be cleared of tables and chairs is that
correct well we're not in control of
that because Charlie's can use it
Woody's can use their existing area but
we will not be putting any tables and
chairs or increasing the number of
tables and chairs currently outside
Woody's in any way associated with this
premises okay well can you explain to me
mr. permissive and the environment or
office now Mr Hudson sorry
how are you going to ensure that people
aren't customers of the new venue aren't
going to purchase alcoholic drinks or
any kind of drink and sitting outside
would eat a dozen chair because at night
and in the morning at 7.30 when they put
the tables and chairs out there is going
to be more places for people to sit 30
smoke debates and do more customers
outside the tables and chairs are going
to be the same that would is that's like
this and this could be no change okay I
hear what you sound but because I live
there I see 870 that's fine ry I know it
doesn't exist
and license for Woody's but I will speak
to environmental officer should any
nuisance or a current and after KCC for
the amount of tables and chairs that are
out there but obviously it doesn't get
Connie's license now I hear that it
won't take up any more of your time
thank you
Thank You Jessica okay does the
environmental and just mr. Brown want to
sum up say anything I think I pretty
much covered everything in our
submission thank you Joe
okay does the applicant want to sum up
and say anything no I think we've
covered everything and we've heard what
the objector said we've worked this out
with mr. Brown we feel it's a workable
solution and we will pay attention to
what the objectors although I think
second detector hasn't actually appeared
globally but I think we've said
everything that needs to be said and I
will simply invite the community to grab
the application with the conditions as
suggested by mr. Brown and we will
ensure that we do not cause any
disturbance to join the occupiers and we
are now aware the identity of the lady
if she has any problems comes and speaks
to mr. Hicks I'm sure he will be happy
to deal with them sorry Sam I've got one
more question and sorry just to write
written well better ask good then that
machine in the application I'm reading
and I might be reading it wrong so I
please miss I am
2.2 and says all tables and chairs for
any form or seating associated with
these premises up that place on the
y-axis shall be removed by 20 to 30
onwards well yes but that was before mr.
Brown intervened and remove the license
from the Piazza which we originally
applied for so that does I wonderful
thank you I haven't seen that that's a
it was taken up until this mysterious
come up in this conversation so thank
you Miss Brown
thank you mr. Hicks listening Thank You
Phyllis
thank you Thank You Jessica just asleep
that does the licensing officer want to
sum awfulness no thank you chair okay
thanks penny
okay and so um so the subcommittee we're
now and basically and move off them to a
different room counselor Brown bridge
could you just check with the applicant
whether they're they agree to the
inclusion on the license of all three of
the conditions referred to in the report
okay does the applicant agree to the
conditions that three conditions that
will law yes the conditions proposed by
mr. Brown are agreed by ostrich okay
that's great thank you very much okay so
it's so them things at the end
subcommittee now will and reconvene in
another another room and and we are
notifying the decision we'll sit around
and wait and can you come and can we and
have a time on this fifteen minutes ten
minutes yeah so to everybody
participating in the meeting the process
now is that the three councillors mrs.
Crowley and Gavin happy the legal
representative will leave this meeting
and join their own private meeting to
deliberate as they would do in a normal
physical scenario what will happen now
is in we I personally will stay on this
call and in fifteen minutes from the
point that we adjourn this meeting I
will then give an update to those people
that are remaining in this in this call
so that is mr. Hicks and mr. Dylan ms
Woods and the remaining licensing
offices and at that point we will either
say that the counselors have come to a
decision or that they need additional
time and we will give a updated time at
that point does that make sense to
everybody is that clear how that will
work
that's great yeah Thank You Nicholas
does everyone agree 15 minutes
fine yes thank you Charlotte right
everybody thank you for all be joining
us we can resume the meeting now
I believe that the panel have made a
decision so I'll pass you back to the
Chairman okay thank you
Thank You Nick and the subcommittee's
legal advisor will now read out summary
of the subcommittee's determination and
the recent determination will be
circulated to all parties within five
working days of the hearing so then if
you'd like to read out the decision
thank you Thank You counselor this was
an application for a new premises
license brought by mr. mark Hicks in
respect to 15 the Pride Margay the
applicant seeks a license to allow the
following licensable activities of the
following times like night refreshment
Monday to Sunday 2300
o 130 air was a following day and 2302 o
200 hours the following day on New
Year's Eve the supply of alcohol for
consumption both on and off the premises
Monday to Sunday 10a into Oh 110 a.m.
till 200 hours the following day on New
Year's Eve business proposes I have a
bar and restaurant the applicants
Connie's holds an existing premises
precedence in respect of the premise
located immediately next door at 16 the
bride we have heard evidence from the
applicant licensing and Environmental
Health Services and from a local
resident objecting to this application
this in addition to a second written
objection having paid very careful
attention to all of the evidence that
has been placed before us we are
satisfied that this application amended
as it is not to include any part of the
piazza can be granted the following
conditions were agreed between applicant
environmental health service 1 the
licensed area shall only include the
internal parts of the premises and 2
from midnight on words on each
operational night alcohol for off sale
provisions shall only be provided in a
sealed container the amendment of the
applications remove the piazza from the
scope of the application has rendered
the third condition a great between
applicant and Environmental Health
Service to be relevant we consider that
these two conditions in all the
circumstances appropriate proportion are
necessary for the promotion of the
licensing objectives and we formally
apply them as premises license
that's decision and soft
thank you Kevin okay so that concludes
the meeting today thank you thank you
very much
Jason thank you